foreign
is joining us in Detroit Michigan
Antonia how can we help
Hi how are you we're having a blast
what's going on
so my question today is I don't trust my
boyfriend with money do we have a future
oh I want to back that question up
um let's stop it you added a second part
to it that is not super necessary you
don't trust your boyfriend period yes
what else do you not trust a mom besides
money
um
he I
felt like him
the other women he feel like it's not
cheating but Felicia wow bye what's
what's his explanation for that
I'm sorry can you repeat that what's his
explanation because you said uh he
doesn't think it's cheating so I'm
curious what does he call that
yeah I told him I'm like that's cheating
oh it's not cheating because it's not in
a physical form I'm like you're like
lusting over your women you're seeing
online no boy bro dude
those gas lights Are Burning Brightly
aren't they listen
um let me ask you this so he's not here
to defend himself
no so let me ask you the only person I
got to talk to is that cool
yeah
why do you think so little of my friend
Antonia
that you you're settling for this
well it's not
that yes it is I think yes it is why
you have a point
um I'm a single mother
um with a three-year-old son I'm new
like new to like motherhood me and the
father it didn't work out
um I injured my back at work so
and I'm like I needed this surgery so I
ended up gaining all of this weight you
know like when you have a partner you
expect your partner to be there for you
and I feel like I didn't get that
because like when I was off work for a
year
um when we have fights or anything the
first thing you bring up is oh I paid
your rent well I'm like well like you
might as well say you're a roommate
because you live here we're not married
you know
so it's it's a little bit of everything
so
so is he he's a bit of Security even
though he's not treating you well it's
like well at least he's done that he was
right well and but here's the thing that
so it's really common that all these
other stories that we are told
eventually become the stories we we tell
ourselves
and you've got a narrative that you're
worth less because you gained weight
you've got a narrative that
because you got hurt and you reached out
to the person who was supposed to be
your partner in this in this adventure
called life called raising a kid and he
weaponized that against you and said
well look at what I'm doing for you
um you have the story that you're a
single mom and that you're now somehow
less than all those stories are false
100 of them they're not true
I agree and so I do one thousand percent
believe that whoever you're dating is
probably a lot of fun is probably makes
you laugh and probably makes you feel
loved and all three of those things are
amazing
and he's making other women feel that
way too
and when you say I have a need
I'm uncomfortable with he makes you feel
crazy and stupid for having that thought
or need or feeling not supporting you
yes and so you don't trust him on a
number of different issues money is one
of them I was a train wreck when it came
to money
but I was a trustworthy guy does that
make sense I would never tell somebody
like man that my husband spins like
crazy we figure that out
if I had said
um and I was baiting you a little bit
when I said what else do you not trust
him on if you had said nothing he's
actually super iron Cloud he's
trustworthy then that would have been a
different answer
um but you
ah you're not gonna like this at the end
of the day you don't trust you
yeah and I want you I agree to reinvest
in you that's exactly right let's stay
there for a second Anthony you called
and asked us do we have a future you
know the answer but you John's right you
don't trust your answer so you called
these two yahoos to see what our take
was but your answer is what do you have
a future with this dude yes or no
I don't think so no but see it's the I
don't think so John's on something you
don't trust your own judgment
to kick this guy to the curb and you're
worthy of being trusted dude you're an
awesome mom you're a great employee
you're a good friend you're worthy of
being trusted
thank you is that fair and I'm not just
pulling smoke at you I've hey trust me
you've listened to this show if you if
you were out out to lunch we would tell
you
John here's I'm asking a question on
behalf of my friend okay
just because we make a bad decision
and and we kind of take good judgment
out of the equation for someone in a
relationship doesn't mean that we have
bad judgment the rest of our life true
or false false yeah and in fact uh but
is that what's going on here she knows
it wasn't a good decision maybe she's
made some poor relationship decision all
of a sudden she goes I just don't make
good decisions but that's not true well
I think it's easy to and tell me if I'm
wrong Antonia it's easy to feel like
you're a single mom someone's told you
you've got these defects I'm the only
one that's ever going to love you I'm
the only one that's paying your rent
with my money it's easy to make that
those that voice into your own voice and
you start telling yourself like the
manipulation okay that's right and then
somebody walks along and they're willing
to give you half of themselves
right I'll tell you I love you I'll tell
you you're pretty I'll help pay you the
bills and you start to think that's all
yeah and then yeah and want credit for
it you're getting me for a discount
exactly and you are you start thinking
well this is all that I'm ever gonna get
yeah this is all this is going to be 100
and when this is especially real in
couples that experience infidelity
people often think that the like finding
out that the person you're married to or
you love cheated on you is is the most
devastating part that is devastating
but the most devastating long-term thing
I think is you lose trust in yourself
I can't believe I missed that I can't
believe that I'm worth this little I
didn't even know how what how what a
loser I would like you lose trust in
yourself and it's hard to do anything
it's hard to get a job it's hard to
stand up with your to your kids it's
hard to do anything in your community
because you feel so you feel so small
and so I want you to hear Ken and I tell
you stand up man yeah you're worth too
much you got too much value and
somebody's gonna recognize you for who
you are
um and I also don't want to blow smoke
at you you probably need to go talk to
somebody you probably need to get a
group of women in your life where you
can practice standing up on your own two
feet right now the greatest gift you can
give somebody in the future
um is you working really really hard on
you in this season
is that yeah and that's like that's
another thing too like I know it's like
he weaponized because I because I you
know like I'm a victim of molestation
and things like that so he he uses that
and you know that I suffered from
anxiety done hey hey anybody who
weaponizes that sort of pain done done
he's manipulating you I you know what
James would never allow it but if we had
time I'd call the guy up for you right
now break up with him for you I I would
dump him uh for you it's not the kind of
show we do John is probably not healthy
but that's what I would like to do this
dude is a loser and we know what we do
with losers we fire him we get rid of
them you're out you're done no longer
does he get to play in your world you
are worth so much more Anthony and thank
you we believe in you this is the Ramsey
Show